eduardo facing the team he beat for his
first major league win in 2015. the
left-handed hitting brock holt
1-2
he struck him out 95 miles an hour a
great start for erod four fastballs
right by you two swings and misses balls
downstairs too adolesce garcia
right-handed power batter
and a wave and a miss on a change there
it is that's money that is his money
pitch tailing it away never got there
garcia swinging a miss and he could
swing and miss with the best of them
here's the 2-2
and a fly ball backing up for dugo he's
underneath
side retired one hit one left red sox
coming up miles last time out uh rough
start flies in short sleeves where's the
number 24 and the pitch is swung on hit
high in the air right center field it's
playable for garcia he cuts in front of
peters and makes the catch and brings up
xander bogarts
one of two boguard strikes out swinging
good looking slider from lyles and it's
a one two three bottom of the first
after one were scoreless at fenway low
did not play yesterday he goes lefty
against lefty
says this one is lifted
into left field and it is going to go
off
at green monster and nate lowe is going
to be in with a leadoff double here for
the rangers good for nate lowe to go up
there knowing what he's looking for and
even getting deep into that count
driving that ball off the monster no
score for nick solak back in the big
leagues right-handed batter
first that bat for nick solak back in
the big leagues and it's a ground ball
to the right side that's going to be a
base hit nate lowe around third he's
going to try to score he'll get there
easily and welcome back to the big
leagues nick solak an rbi single that
gives the rangers a one-nothing lead
here in the second inning one nothing
rangers here in the second holt struck
out to start the blocking
and this one is lined to center field
and it's going to get down pozo's around
third he's going to try to score here
comes the throw from verdugo and it is
not in time
it looked like pozo might have got
around the tag a nice slide
from the ranger rookie and it looks like
an rbi single for brock holt and the
rangers now take a two to nothing lead
well you look at where the throw was but
it took him vasquez to the first base
side of the bag but pogo seemed to get
under it so the tying run aboard go
ahead run at the plate christian vasquez
love to atone for that play at the plate
this one is grounded to the right side
and it's going to go past a diving nick
solac
around third is martinez here comes the
throw
and he's out
a great job in right field
by dolis garcia to nail
jd martinez at home play dalbeck 227
he's hit 14 home runs
flies this one to left center that's
well struck peter's back looking to the
wall
gets a big piece of the monster he's in
the second base stall back with a double
that was on cue
yes it was number 260 for the red sox
doubles double doubles double for
dawnback got a breaking ball i thought
he left the ballpark it's a slider that
didn't do anything and he had a
beautiful swing at it top of the order
now [ __ ] it would fly ball to deep right
center on the first pitch lyle's throat
and he's on again
dalbeck around he's going to score
that's an rbi single
kk strikes his 48th run batted in
and the socks are on the board boy you
gotta love that stroke i mean that
slider doesn't try to pull ball outside
though he doesn't pull off i love when
[ __ ] does that so with nobody out
raphael devers will step in he swings at
the first pitch and hits a high fly ball
into deep center field peters is back
jumps and he makes the catch
and now there might be a play here at
first base [ __ ] hernandez came way
around first and he is out for the
double play
what a job by peters in center field bad
base running from [ __ ] hernandez
an excellent execution
by the rangers on that throw from center
field now [ __ ] doesn't want to leave but
it did appear that he was out on his
fly down to verdugo in left center field
his first time up
fastball is swung on in line this one
will get down and it will be off the
wall
martinez feels it ibanya is going for
two the throw is offline he's in there
safely
and luckily that throw was backed up as
it got past hernandez back to the top of
the order now and brockhold
as he taps one back off the ankle of
rodriguez it deflects to the right side
of the infield racing around third of
banya is trying to score here's the
throw ivanya's dives and he scores the
throw gets past vasquez and hulk moves
down to second so rodriguez had no idea
where that ball was after it hit off of
his ankle that was a playable ball it
was not hit all that hard
but rodriguez essentially kicked it with
his ankle to this vacant spot on the
right side of the infield and ibanya is
getting waved around by tony beasley
scores on the play it's three to one
texas
and then it turned into an error as
isaiah conor falefa slugs the first
pitch that he sees and this one is going
to short hop the green monster holt will
score easily
and ikf is in with an rbi double
the rangers swinging some very nice bats
here against eduardo rodriguez
it's an oldie scratchia
sawamura set here comes his 3-2 to
garcia ground ball hit to the left side
backhanded by bogart's long throw and he
throws it away
isaiah connor for aleppo will score
dolis garcia is going to stay at first
he made no attempt to go to second
probably going to be ruled an infield
hit and then an error which allowed
isaiah connor falefa to score which
would be the second era of the inning
for the red sox fourth rangers leading
it five to one and jordan lyles had to
sit for quite some time there 3-2 here
swinging a miss
good-looking breaking pitch there from
jordan lyles gets kyle schwerber for the
first out third strikeout
for jordan lyles
a good fastball up and in to finish off
renfro and a nice job by jordan lyles to
keep the momentum in the favor of the
rangers here's
nick drove in the first run of the game
when he poked an opposite field single
to right
2-0 and there's a swing there's a drive
toward the monster in left center field
that one is way back and that one is
halfway up on the wall
so lack digging for second base the
throw is late and nick is in there with
a double
so solac rips one off the monster and
now here comes andy ebanyas
and delivers andabanya's lines one left
center base hit that'll score another
one as solac is home and that one goes
all the way to the fence into second
with a double as a bunyas
as the rangers have double itis tonight
and they lead this ball game six to one
well he starts closed he opens up give a
banya some credit for squaring that
baseball up getting it in the gap so the
red sox trailing six to one have two men
on with one out
and here's jd martinez
and fires
and he struck him out swinging
curveball got him lyle's using the
curveball now as he goes through the
order a third time he was heavily
reliant on the hard slider early in the
game on the o2 once again fifth pitch of
the f-bat and there's a fastball and it
is lifted to left field
shouldn't be an easy out for ibanez it
is and jordan lyles has given the ranger
six innings of one run ball against the
boston red sox he has been locked in
who came back yesterday from triple a
round rock
high chop
charging it kiki throws bang bang and he
got him
outstanding yo he can make some plays
can he he really can such an athletic
player i know i saw this little chopper
i said i don't know this guy but he kind
of perfect hurry up get rid of it bang
bang it first two men out here in the
seventh and that brings up bobby
dahlbeck this is vital to the rangers
for these guys to be able to go this
deep in games as this one's lifted high
into the air left field ibanez going
back not quite to the track will now
come back in a few steps and make the
catch and it's a one two three seventh
inning for jordan lyles what a terrific
performance by the right-hander here
tonight now perez in some hot water
that's a good fastball this one goes off
the glove of vasquez and both runners
will advance which means another run for
the rangers isaiah kind of falafel
scores on what might be a pass ball
rangers leading 7-1 here's pozo
here's the pitch to pozo and that one is
drill to left that's a base hit and an
rbi for yoel it is eight one texas
as adolesce crosses the plate pozo has
his fourth run batted in
andy two doubles today run batted in a
fly out in a walk so the pitch is
drilled over first that's a fair ball
it ricochets off the side wall it scores
pozo and bounces away from the right
fielder renfro
all the way around comes solac and to
third base on the play goes ibanez
it is 10 to 1 texas
and that will be another red sox error
their fifth of the game as renfro will
be charged with one and alex verdugo is
the last hope now for the boston's
pitch and a bouncing ball hit out the
second this should end the game
uh flipped to first by solac it's over
the rangers have won it by the score of
ten to one
you